thank
you see oh my God I was I sat down I was
like that's not a good host I was like
wait hello than you for your service I
know thank you so much and everyone
watching also in service how are youall
doing good yeah do you usually come to
work together to do something no we used
to we used to when we used to we both
used to work here at NBC yeah true but
it's been a minute it's been a few
minutes a few minutes a few minutes I
like it so you you had some health
issues but you're doing well right I did
uh I was uh late right about this time
last year I was in the hospital uh I
went in for one thing uh ended up having
surgery for five so it was buy one get
one get four free oh my that's scary no
it was really a very scary time Kelly
it's a very scary time and Al is one who
likes to look forward not backward okay
The Optimist which is great ever The
Optimist but it was a very very
difficult time and we are so blessed to
have him in full form and just great but
um I have to say too your um
granddaughter she kind of played a role
right yes yeah I found out while I was
in the hospital that my oldest girl
Courtney uh was expecting our first
grandchild and there she is little Sky
oh you can all go a I
know so special but I think more than
anything else I think just having no
knowing that she was coming along over
this last year because it's been a
progression but you've just gotten
stronger and stronger and so here he is
so now when he drops his underwear and
his stuff on the floor whatever and I
want to get upset with him I'm just like
you know they're there at least I could
have been dead yeah oh my God he's going
to use it that's going to be his car he
this is what you PR it's your fault you
saved me sorry you didn't want me to go
anywhere um so I I have to say like was
it odd you he was singing on Broadway
that's like not normally how he say and
was in waitress right how how was that
first of all did you love it are you
going to do it again I don't know if
anybody really wants to see that but it
was one of those things where they said
uh my agent call said they want you to
be in waitress I said oh the hunky Dr
Pomer no they want you to play Old Joe
cool got it it's kind of a bit of a
downer but but it was fun I had a great
ton I know I was going to say was it
interesting to watch him in that way cuz
you don't normally I was shocked I was
shocked because I had you more nervous I
think she was more scared because I was
going to make a fool of myself no I
think that you one live he would sing
that much for us at home I think he was
a little self-conscious so when we saw
him on stage the first time it was the
first time I saw him do it and I
actually teared up I was like I actually
can sing a little bit that's so cool so
it was really a lot of fun and again it
was a really nice title of a song taken
from an old man yeah I know you were
like down in the RO but I actually love
that I think old Jo would be fun that'd
be cool so wait I want to talk about
your new documentary it's uh it's called
it's called gaining ground the fight for
Blackland uh it was it it it's this this
incredible problem in in this country
where in 1920 there was about 20 million
Acres of of Farmland owned by by black
farmers and we're down to less than 2
million now and through different heirs
property rights where if one person
decides they want to sell everybody has
to sell the lack of proper wills and
things like that so we look at this
through uh the lens of how do we reverse
this and uh we had the partner we were
partnered with John Deere the tractor
folks yeah oh I know who they are to uh
interesting uh John Deere was an
abolitionist you know so uh back in the
days I don't know the back story on John
Deere that's interesting yeah yeah so so
they they really tried to put in place a
a a legacy that will help going forward
Farmers you know get their land the
interesting fact is uh the great the
fastest growing demographic for New
farmers people of color and women so I
would be one of those people because I'm
doing that on my rant yeah there you go
and it is a hard it's a hard life so but
it's it's very fascinating and I think
everybody wants to get back to like non
GMO and like really healthy stuff cuz we
all know that that's medicine the table
we are what we eat literally yeah don't
I know it so it's two things you just
released a book recently what is the
title I love this book it's called
Lessons Learned and cherished the
teacher who changed my life and it's a
collection of essays from a lot of
notable people some of them maybe you
don't know a lot you do who talk about
that teacher who just changed something
for them and it's so inspir and it's a
salute to teachers oh I'm going to love
that copy for me I know I'm very exced
for but also um congratulations cuz you
were named 2028 thank you thank you with
David mure I'm so excited to
St thank you you're clapping but you're
kind of competitor not really she does
real news and I just oh my God do not do
not gosh but I'm just really thrilled
because Barbara Walters have course
started this program along with HS and
to be there in the space that Barbara
occupied all those years after having
worked with her for so many years I was
going to say she was a mentor right she
was absolutely a mentor I watched and
followed Barbara I mean I did she was
iconic I grew up watching her so I'm
just it's a great responsibility and I'm
just honored and humbled oh you're
beaming about it yeah your eyes are
smiling that's wonderful I love that do
you think it's gotten better for women
in news I oh
absolutely of course we see women in so
many different roles right but it's more
important to see women behind the scenes
and we are starting to see but we need
more women behind the scenes but the the
industry has changed tremendously I mean
to see so many heads of news divisions
and so forth it's really great to see no
and especially when it's like a
producing team and they're producing
something like if it's a woman producing
something about a woman it's like that
makes sense those are yeah those are
things that make sense so how's today
going I was just there recently I know I
know in fact our our uh the head of the
today brand Libby least our our our Uber
producer and you know we have a great
time it's just a a really good family I
you have a great crew Hoda Carson Craig
Chanel Chanel Jones just ran the New
York City marathon for the first time
did any that was who I was waving at
from my house cuz I was like never
me Al ran it Al ran it years ago you did
I did I did there's too many things that
can go wrong with chafing and people I
hear have to go to the bathroom and I'm
like and they just go and I had I had
chafed nipples I'm just not about that
life but I'm so proud of people that do
it I'll give you a sense of how fast I
ran it our daughter Leela said at the
end she said Daddy what did the snail
say on top of the turtle I don't
know but you like what did the snil say
when he finished something yeah you have
covered both of you have covered so many
military stories is there one that
sticks out to you deorah I remember
prior to the 911 attack we had another
attack on us soil the very very first
time and I did a story up in U
Massachusetts about a young woman who
was getting ready to go to college who
decided she wanted to go and serve her
country she was called to action and to
duty and there were a number of people
who were deciding I want to serve my
country and I remember just being so in
awe of that that whole Spirit of w to
serve selflessness so that was actually
one that I will never forget I was
really very impressed by that young
woman called to a high purpose that's
really really beautiful what about you
you know I I got I read about this story
it was the Battalion the 6 Triple 8 it
was the only Battalion of all women of
color who were sent
overseas to they were the 68 Coastal
Battalion there was a backlog of about
18 months male to and from from the
front lines that could not get and they
were led by a black the first black
female Colonel they went over first to
England then behind the Enemy Lines in
France and within six months had the
mail service running to and from and I
had the pleasure and honor of
interviewing Miss Lena King who is still
alive she's 101 years old W
[Applause]
yes there were there were 855 of these
women only six are still alive and and I
got to meet one other but also got to
interview Miss King she's still sharp as
attack and and so they said one of the
things she said was we we wanted to show
that we loved our country even though
our country didn't always love us back
yeah well that's real love yeah I I love
that what the Today Show did too y'all
actually lobbied for these women to be
that's right they got their they got
their Congressional Medal of Honor May
many
[Applause]
of it really meant meant a lot meant a
lot and it does matter getting those
letters matters like getting that's
that's really important before emails
you yeah absolutely that's what I'm
saying yeah this is it's even more
important well everybody you can see Al
on the Today's Show every morning on NBC
if you didn't already know that and also
in the third hour of today and also
watch Deborah Friday evenings on 2020 on
[Music]
ABC
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home